THE GAME
UNEQUIVOCALLY FOR WOMEN
AT EVERY LEVEL.
>>> EARLIER I SPOKE TO NADIA
NADINE.
SHE IS AN AFGHAN DANISH
FOOTBALLER.
-- IN 2000, OUR CONVERSATION
BEGAN WITH HER MEMORIES OF
GROWING UP IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> BEFORE THE TALIBAN, WE HAD A
GREAT LIFE, SAFE ENVIRONMENT.
MY MOM AND DAD PROVIDED THE BEST
LIFE FOR US POSSIBLE.
AND THEN AFTER THE TALIBAN
GAINED POWER MY DAD WAS KILLED.
ALL THAT TIME WAS A LIFE WITH A
LOT OF FEAR, POOR, AND TRYING TO
SURVIVE.
IT'S ALMOST TWO MOVIES, TWO
DIFFERENT WORLDS.
>> HOW DID YOU GET OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN?
>> WE GOT OUT -- WE WERE
PROBABLY AMONG THE MORE
FORTUNATE ONES.
MY MOM SOLD EVERYTHING SHE HAD.
WE HAD A HUMAN SMUGGLER.
TO PAKISTAN, A PASSPORT, FIRST
TO ITALY AND THEN A TRUCK TO
DENMARK.
SO -- A LONG WAY.
>> THIS IS A REMARKABLE JOURNEY.
I'VE GOT TO ASK YOU.
HOW DID YOU GET INTO FOOTBALL?
>> I ALWAYS SAY IT'S PROBABLY
FATE BECAUSE THE REFUGEE CAMP I
WAS STAYING IN IN DENMARK WAS
JUST BESIDE THIS AMAZING
FOOTBALL FIELD AND A FOOTBALL
CLUB.
THAT'S THE FIRST TIME I GOT TO
SEE GIRLS PLAY FOOTBALL.
RIGHT AWAY I LOVED THE GAME.
AND SINCE THEN I NEVER LEFT THE
BALL.
>> I WANT OUR VIEWERS TO GET A
SENSE OF YOUR SUCCESS.
YOU MOVED FROM PLAYING FOOTBALL
EVENTUALLY IN DENMARK TO PSG IN
PARIS.
THERE YOU WON THE FRENCH
CHAMPIONSHIP LAST SEASON WITH
THE TEAM.
THAT IS AMAZING.
HOW WAS THAT?
>> IT WAS GREAT.
IT WAS THE FIRST TIME IN THE
CLUB'S HISTORY THAT THEY WON THE
LEAGUE, AND THAT WAS THE REASON
I SIGNED WITH PEEN GEE.
I WANTED TO WIN WITH THEM, ONE
OF THE BIGGEST ACHIEVEMENTS.
>> LOOK, IT'S BEEN QUITE THE
SUMMER FOR YOU, WINNING THE
FRENCH CHAMPIONSHIP WITH PSG
ONLY WEEKS LATER.
THE TALIBAN TAKING OVER POWER IN
KABUL.
WHAT'S BEEN RUNNING THROUGH YOUR
MIND WHEN YOU SEE THESE IMAGES
COMING OUT OF AFGHANISTAN?
>> I WASN'T UNDERSTANDING WHAT
WAS HAPPENING.
IT SOUNDED LIKE DEJA VU.
I NEVER REALLY THOUGHT IT WOULD
COME BACK TO THIS.
IT FEELS LIKE HISTORY REPEATING
ITSELF.
SO THAT WAY IT WAS CONFUSING.
I COULDN'T UNDERSTAND IT AND IT
WAS UPSETTING HOW THEY'RE
GAINING MORE POWER.
AND NOW THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
RUNNING THE COUNTRY, YEAH, MAKES
ME UPSET, MAKES ME ANGRY.
I DON'T THINK THEY DESERVE IT.
I DON'T THINK THAT TERRORIST
GROUPS SHOULD HAVE THAT MUCH
POWER.
>> THEY HAVE JUST ANNOUNCED THE
FORMATION OF A GOVERNMENT WHICH
IS NOT AT ALL-INCLUSIVE.
IT HAS NO WOMEN REPRESENTATION.
IN FACT, THE TALIBAN SAID WOMEN
IN AFGHANISTAN WILL BE BANNED
FROM PLAYING ANY KIND OF SPORT.
IT, QUOTE, EXPOSES THEIR BODIES.
YOU MUST BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FUTURE FOR AFGHANISTAN'S
SPORTING TEAMS, AREN'T YOU?
>> IF YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO PLAY
MUSIC OR LISTEN TO MUSIC, HOW DO
YOU THINK SPORTS IS GOING TO BE
IN THE CONVERSATION?
IT'S MEN TRYING TO CONTROL
PEOPLE BY FEAR.
I DON'T SEE SPORTS IN THE FUTURE
IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> HOW DOES THAT MAKE YOU FEEL?
>> LIKE UPSET.
IT UPSETS ME, YOU KNOW.
BORN IN A COUNTRY WHERE YOU'RE
NOT EVEN ALLOWED TO PLAY A
SPORT.
IT'S SUCH A BASIC THING.
LIKE IT DOESN'T HARM ANYONE.
YOU ARE JUST HAVING FUN.
YOU'RE JUST LIKEN JOYING YOUR
SELF.
YOU'RE ACTUALLY TRYING TO
IMPROVE YOUR HEALTH, TRYING TO
LEARN.
WHY IT'S A BAD THING, I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE IN MY
BRAIN.
AND THEN THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE 9
POWER TO RUN A COUNTRY, WHAT
DOES THAT SAY ABOUT THE COUNTRY?
AND WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE THE
COUNTRY'S FUTURE?
>> TO THE THOUSANDS OF AFGHAN
WOMEN THAT HAVE A DREAM TO PLAY
SPORT IN AFGHANISTAN, WHAT'S
YOUR MESSAGE TO THEM?
>> YOU KNOW, THE MESSAGE I WOULD
SAY NO MATTER HOW HARD THE TIMES
ARE, ONE SHOULD NEVER LOSE HOPE.
ALWAYS TRY TO FEEL OR THINK THAT
IT'S GOING TO CHANGE AND YOU'RE
ABLE TO CHANGE IT THROUGH YOUR
MIND-SET AND ATTITUDE.
SAYING THIS, IT DOESN'T REALLY
HIT HOME BECAUSE TO ME, EVEN
WHEN I'M TRYING TO IMAGINE THE
FUTURE, IT DOESN'T -- I DON'T
SEE ANY LIGHT.
IT'S VERY DARK.
THE ONLY WAY I CAN SEE THEM,
LIKE HAVING A FUTURE IN TERMS OF
WHERE THEY'RE ACTUALLY ALLOWED
TO DO BASIC STUFF, BASIC HUMAN
RIGHTS IS IF THE TALIBAN REALLY
LOOSENS UP BECAUSE OF THE
PRESSURE OF THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY.
OR THEY SOMEHOW ARE REMOVED.
>> IF YOU HAD A MESSAGE TO THE
TALIBAN THEMSELVES, WHAT WOULD
IT BE?
>> EDUCATE YOUR SELF.
IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
LIKE, THERE ARE SO MANY
QUESTIONS I HAVE AND I THINK I
WOULD TELL THEM, YEAH, EDUCATE
YOUR SELF.
SEE HOW THE WORLD WORKS AROUND
YOU.
AND